[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 my name is caleb denby
and tonight i want to take you through
some games
from the legends of chess final where
magnus carlsen
just simply cruised to an easy victory
magnus truly a legend of chess a chess
legend
had quite a phenomenal tournament and
really
once he found his stride there was no
turning back uh and he really showed it
in this final
so of course his opponent was yan
napomnishi
and we are going to be taking a look at
those games that they played
and we're going to see how magnus just
dominated
uh the entire field including yan here
tonight
so to start off with i wanted to show
this game where magnus had
white against yan yan throughout the
tournament had been choosing
uh this grunfeld defense
against many of his opponents that had
the white pieces
and it had very mixed results for him uh
he was getting some really good
positions out of the opening
some pretty bad positions uh positions
that were
not so good but then he managed to turn
around and so it had very much been a
back and forth tournament for yon
with the grunfeld we see here though
that
magnus opts not to go into the true
grunfeld after something like
c4 which would allow black to play the
move d5
going for the grunfeld and instead
magnus chooses
this move bishop f4
and so what this means is that black now
could play the move
d5 and we would be in a very very
standard
uh d4 d5 opening position
however this actually probably isn't in
black's best interest here uh in general
when you go uh d4 d5 and
you have this sort of position the fee
encoded bishop actually isn't going to
be
the strongest piece in the world uh why
is that well it's because
white's play is very natural you go e3
let's say bishop g7
and something like either c4 or just
developing normally let's go with c4
e6 knight c3 and something like c6
for example so black has this nice setup
where he
has built a strong triangle to support
this pawn here
you can imagine these positions with the
bishop on f5 as well
and white still has a really solid
control over the d4
pawn notably magnus is not committed to
something like the london yet with
bishop f4 he can still go for these
positions with c4
and this is actually going to make this
bishop on g7 look a little bit silly
because this d4 pawn is going to be
quite strong quite well defended
perhaps for those reasons black still
continues with bishop g7 but doesn't opt
to go for this
symmetrical battle in the center with
pawns on d4 and d5
we see e3 king's side castles bishop e2
notably magnus delang choosing where he
wants to put this pawn
depending on what black plays and now we
see the move d6
so jan definitively chooses not to go
for this structure with d5 and set
opting
for the king's indian structures with d6
and perhaps part of the reason why he
selected this is what i was talking
about here
with the bishop not looking great
after d4 d5 in the game we
see white castle
and i want to ask you guys in the chat
to find some candidate moves here
for black what do you think black should
be trying to achieve
in this opening uh black has pretty much
chosen what he wants to achieve
with this move d6 and so now i'm asking
you guys at home to try and identify
what it is that black is actually
playing for
and then once you've found that try and
find out how you can achieve it how can
you actually make it a reality here
yes not at home this week back in the
studio
back in the studio so there's a few
different ideas
smart is saying the move bishop f5 uh
yashas is playing uh the move c5 anish
also says c5
and yeah c5 is definitely one of the
playable
plans here for black the idea is to
expand uh or sorry not expand but to
open up
this diagonal for this bishop to make
this piece rather strong
however due to the way that white has
played maybe he could consider
playing c3 here and this might be a very
effective way
of playing against this idea of c5
because as white has not committed this
pawn to c4
going for these benoni style planes can
be a little bit more difficult right
this pawn on c3 does a great job
of supporting this pawn on d4 and magnus
might be a little bit happy
with this the other plan that i wanted
to mention
is actually going for this move e5 this
is sort of the most combative way
to challenge this center and i think
this is sort of what yan had
in mind of course there are some obvious
uh things preventing black from playing
this move for example
white is controlling the square three
times and it's going to be rather
difficult
to get this move into play and that's
probably how jan arrived at this
idea of knight h5 as for this bishop f5
move
i don't think it's a bad move by any
means it's just a good developing move
but why is it showing the threat
i'm not so sure
uh now we're good to go ben thank you
though
it's showing the threat which i used to
know how to get rid of
but i just do not remember
oh well you'll just see the threats that
black is making
so bishop f5 not a bad move at all just
a normal developing move
but it does allow white time to do
something very very important
and what that thing is is preserving
this bishop jan didn't want to give
magnus time
to preserve this bishop because this
bishop is one of the main reasons
why black is not so comfortable playing
this move e5 just yet
that's why the computer was so expertly
highlighting the fact that knight h5
was the threat so the question arises
why not play knight h5 now
and that's exactly what jan chose to do
and here magnus found a really
interesting idea that i was actually not
familiar with until looking at this game
uh so generally in these positions
knight h5
is a successful way to sort of corral
this
bishop but who can find a way
to potentially save this bishop from
being captured who sees
the deep idea that magnus carlsen
came up with here to to save this bishop
who has it here
aha thank you to chess king in the chat
solving my technical issues
so chess space arabia does have the idea
here
it takes advantage of the fact that
white has placed his pieces
in this manner with this light squared
bishop on e2
he's very ready to make threats to this
knight on h5
so immediately if you try to threaten
this knight of course it doesn't matter
the knight can capture the bishop
and if you play like this you even lose
a pawn to boot
but white does have this idea of
repositioning this bishop first
now black must try to chase the bishop
away if he does want to still take it
and only now after h6 and g5 black has
actually
undefended this knight and this allows
white to play this idea
of knight f to d2 and so here we see
that uh black is not having such an easy
time
capturing this bishop the move g takes
h4
actually can be played and it will be
met with bishop takes h5
and if there are any bobby fischer fans
in the chat
you may recognize this type of position
from a certain world championship match
where we did have a slightly different
scenario
where white was able to capture on
h5 and after g takes h5 uh fischer did
get a similar pawn structure
but the same ideas sort of hold true
here
that were true in that match with this
open g file
black is going to be able to exert a
little bit of pressure here
and these pawns while they look awful
actually aren't all that weak the black
king is going to be doing
okay with this dark squared bishop
around to protect it
additionally black now does have the
time to break in the center
with a move like e5
for example takes takes h3 to cement
these pawns and something like queen g5
would be quite interesting for black
yondo was not so interested in going for
these clever ideas
another idea was actually to step to f4
with this knight
highlighting the fact that uh
you know this bishop is still a problem
that you have to solve
and here if you save the dark squared
bishop you might end up losing the light
squared bishop
and once again these positions are
always going to be very very interesting
janmo just backed down from the
challenge
and i don't think this is something that
black really should have
done there are some scenarios
after bishop g3 where having included
h6 and g5 is going to be beneficial for
black in these positions
uh and that is because black is able to
contest
this f4 square so for example
let's say if black passes and white
plays the move e4
now all of a sudden it's going to be a
little bit more difficult to play this
move
f4 and black is even going to have ideas
of rerouting
to this f4 square himself like let's say
black passes again and white plays
another bad move all of a sudden
knight h5 and black is probably
significantly better
so h6 g5 is sometimes a good idea for
black in these bononi kings indian type
positions
for the reason that it controls the f4
square and this can be quite useful for
black
however the key point here is that
magnus is not committed to this move
e4 and that is going to be the idea
that we see in this game because magnus
is not committed to e4
he is quite ready to contest this f4
square and so h6 and g5 turn out to just
be weakening moves
for black in this case and i think this
is a great example of magnus carlsen
just having
fantastic chess understanding whereas
jan
maybe thought he could get away with
something here but not against
the world champion when he's on form
so we'll see for the remainder of this
game magnus's moves
are quite directly aimed at taking
advantage
of this weakness of h6g5
meanwhile jan is really getting no
advantage
from having having played these moves
the extra space on the king's side is
sort of meaningless
because white is contesting all of those
squares
and that's the really instructive lesson
that i hope you guys can take away
from this opening here
many bononi players might know this idea
of playing h6 and g5 as being good in
some positions
but without the understanding of why
then you're just going to be led astray
and you're going to start playing it in
positions
where it doesn't actually make sense and
this is one of those positions where it
doesn't make sense
h6 g5 gives you control of f4 and the
opportunity to capture this bishop
in this case those two things are
irrelevant the bishop is alive
and white can contest this square with
the pawn on
e3 okay moving along jan now plays the
move knight c6
like i said he is aiming to control the
e5
square and this is something
that black has achieved by pushing this
knight away from f3
the hold on e5 has been weakened
slightly
and magnus plays a pretty interesting
move here he develops this knight out to
c3
rather than playing something like c4 or
c3 himself
just bringing the knight out to c3
and i think the reason for this is
because he realized
that the fight for the d5 square isn't
going to be very very relevant
until a little bit later in the game he
would much rather have this pawn
back on c2 able to come to c3 to stunt
this bishop after the opening up of the
diagonal
or even uh to just stay on c2
to guard some squares later on notably
on c4
it's also taking away squares from the
white pieces and we'll see that that
becomes relevant later on as well
so just knight c3 is a way to develop
and control the center without really
committing
to too much here once again
as always every move in chess comes sort
of with the downside especially pawn
moves
and while c4 does gain some control of
the center
it also gives up control of other
squares so we see magnus opt not to go
for it here and yan plays the natural
move e5
d takes e5 knight takes e5 and now once
again i'd like to ask you guys at home
to try and find magnus's next move
or just try to come up with a short term
plan
to activate the white pieces
uh so steve is asking why not bishop g4
for black up to this point
uh white has had that square controlled
just just too many times
now now black could consider it because
these two knights are here
but bishop g4 in the previous positions
would would just lose a piece
chess king says 94 ideas bringing
one of the knights to e4
yashas is saying h4 or f4
and that's along the right idea here
chest space arabia says bishop e5 de5
and knight c4
followed by bishop f3 so i'm not so sure
that uh white can actually get away with
this plan but
let's talk about some other plans first
uh
knight e4 actually doesn't do a whole
lot for
white in this specific case uh these
ideas seem good to loosen black's
control of d5
but c6 d5 are likely ideas that black
has already had in mind
additionally after takes and takes the
black bishop is just going to be opened
up a little bit
and it's going to be black who's coming
a bit faster with stuff like d5
for example if the knight retreats c6
black has good
control and an open bishop
uh if you do want to take on e5 do you
take c5
something like knight c4 this isn't
really terrible for white but
something like queen e7 and after the
move e4
the bishop pair is sort of the bishop
pair here right bishop e6 is going to
follow
and we'll have the contested d-file as
well
and white doesn't have very very clear
pieces are very very square
square very very clear squares for his
pieces took me a few tries
uh for example if bishop f3 immediately
the move e4
is going to be an issue so the idea like
i
hinted at earlier is to take advantage
of these weaknesses
that black has created and so
nobody in the chat actually mentioned
the idea of e4
this is what i thought might be natural
to most players
but you can see here that black is sort
of well set up against this idea
right this h6 g5 pawn structure is aimed
against the idea of playing with the
extra space in the center now something
like knight g6
is going to be very very natural and
black can start to take over
these dark squares on the king's side so
as
yasha's kind of hinted at i do really
enjoy
the idea of f4 and that is exactly what
magnus carlsen plays
in this position i will say that perhaps
he could have been a little bit more
ready to play the move f4
with the move h3 h3 and the idea
is quite simply to defend the g4 square
so that
after the idea of f4 there is no knight
landing on the g4 square that being said
magnus just plays it immediately and
does allow black
to step to this g4 square uh himself
now white has to deal with a problem so
he solves this problem with rook to f3
uh knight c4 was also definitely worth
considering but rook f3
is simple enough to defend the pawn and
now black simply plays the move
rook e8 and white plays the move knight
to f1 okay
so what do we have here now well we have
a pretty unorthodox looking position
in the center right neither side is
occupying the center
with a pawn just yet but we do see them
trying to
kind of combat it from the sides or sort
of from behind
with the pawn on d6
and what this means is that
the center is very very open and when
the center is very very open like this
sometimes pawns aren't enough to sort of
control the center when the pawn when
the center is open
and the pawns aren't there to control it
what i'm trying to get at is that
this is when it's time to control the
center using pieces
and that's what we'll we'll see magnus
carlsen does a great job
of doing here so some of black's
best moves for example would be the
slightly strange looking
knight to h7 why is this one of black's
best moves
well because it's controlling the center
with the pieces
and preparing to control the center even
more with an idea like
f5 and ideas of c6 and d5 right it's all
about central control
another idea for black is to simply
capture on
f4 to be able to once again
better control the center with his
pieces knight h5 to follow as well
and we'll see that it's black who is
trying very very hard
to control these central squares now in
the game
black plays knight h5 which has a
similar idea of controlling the center
but unfortunately after the move bishop
e1 yan does sort of go
astray here
i think now is the time for black to
take
over in the center so while there are
some immediate threats
uh to the king side something like g
takes f4 he takes f4
and then once again going for central
control with us
with a move like c6 i think would have
been very very relevant here
for black the issue is by playing this
move knight h5
he's placed his pieces on slightly
awkward squares and he's going to have
to deal with threats
of h3 that being said
still other moves queen e7 for example
and
even dropping this knight back no this
would be a bad idea because
this is going to be quite strong ideas
of queen e7
would still be fine for black fighting
against these ideas
and following up with c6 and d5
in the game though after bishop e1
black tried to solve these problems with
the move f5
and f5 is an attempt to take over the
e4 square and so you might be thinking
well what's wrong with that
and i'm going to ask you guys at home
now to see if you can find
what white's idea should be here against
the move f5
great wolf says but what about the
diagonal of
death i think he might be referring
to the a to g8 diagonal
which might be on the right track
so f5 was actually aimed against this
idea
of h3 now this knight is still going to
come back but black is contesting the g4
square
and can likely consider ideas of g4
for example rook f2 hitting the knight
and g4
this was the point of f5 because neon
was worried about this idea of h3
and still was fighting to control the
center
so e4 is a pretty interesting one i
think the issue is not that it hangs the
e4 pawn
which you were offering us some tactical
solutions but f4
would be left behind once again h6g5
playing for control of f4 but in these
positions it is favorable for white
because white still has this pawn on e3
so yes in fact the idea for white here
is to play bishop c4
check once again controlling the center
with
the pieces rather than the pawns
uh and with bishop c4 if a move like
king
h8 then bishop f7 as someone mentioned
is a tactic so if a move like king f8
instead
now quite simply the move h3 is still
going to be quite strong it takes takes
and something like rook f2 and the issue
now
for black is that if you try something
like c6
you've weakened your king side a bit too
much and g4
is is going to be coming through with
pretty devastating effects
in fact i think white is sort of just
winning a piece here
so now life is pretty awkward for black
you have to try something like f4 but i
can even still
win this piece with the move bishop e2
uh due to all of these threats instead
of king f8 the move bishop e6 was played
the idea being takes takes h3
knight uh g to f6 now after fg5
hg5 uh white can simply win a pawn
on f5 this light squared bishop was two
important
for black and now white goes up a pawn
with a winning position so what all
went wrong for black well
tactically things went wrong because he
put his pieces
on loose squares and positionally things
started going wrong once he played
this move way back here knight f6
allowing bishop g3
when all of a sudden these pawns don't
make the most sense in the world
it's what allowed magnus to go for these
interesting ideas
of playing f4 and after these
interesting positional
uh ideas by magnus jan was unable to
deal with this pressure to the center to
the king's side and that's what
allowed magnus to break through and win
this game
let's look at the end of it though as
well rook takes f5
and yan chose the move bishop h6 he
needed to
clear this square away for the knights
g4 is played anyways knight back to g7
rook back to f3 and queen up to d7
but you know this is sort of just uh
sort of just awful now for
black down a pawn and none of his pieces
really making sense the play now for
white is very natural
you bring the knight out to contest some
of these squares that have been weakened
by this pawn moving to g5
we have rook a to e8s and magnus simply
defends this pawn with bishop f2
we have queen c6 and finally we see this
pawn step to e4
it's job of controlling f4 has sort of
been completed
there's no black knight immediately
stepping to this square anymore
knight d7 played in the game going for
this dark square
but after knight d5 yan had seen enough
and simply resigned this game
with uh this awful awful position
on the board uh one of those positions
where white's not up mating material or
anything not up
anything huge but the position is just
so bad that's
jan could not bear to look at it anymore
and resigned this game
play might have continued with something
like rook f8
rook c3 this queen moves away
takes on c7 for example knight back to
f6
and just just anything here anything
here
is enough
and white would now be up uh i guess
still
only two pawns but it feels like so much
more with black having very very limited
counter play uh okay so any questions
about this game
i think i saw one a little bit earlier
on
asking why not uh
c5 playing for bishop d4 check i'm not
sure where you meet
uh another oh so you probably mean g
takes f4 and something like c5
so getting rid of this pawn on e3 first
uh
okay and yeah this idea is fine you're
still walking into the same issues
of h3 right and we have this square
defended enough times
if you play the move knight e3 i can
just capture
[Music]
and something oh well this guy this guy
would be hanging
any other questions about this game
don't think he should have resigned that
early yeah
it was kind of an early resignation i
don't think it was out of respect
i think it was out of just
uh the psychological damage that would
be done uh
trying to play that position out
honestly it is it is
quite dead lost
um bishop takes c6 rook takes e6 queen
d5
so yeah queen d5 here i think would just
mean uh
i mean queen e8 and there's no way to
add more pressure
to this rook immediately queen f7 would
be coming soon
or something like c65 to break this pin
and then black would be okay i guess f5
is hanging
but then then e3 is hanging and things
would
still be a game 93
rookie 3 check king h8
life goes on right it's not over just
yet
why didn't he play for e5 without trying
to get rid of the bishop well i think
that's
probably closer to what he should have
done here
just something like rookie 8 for example
knight bd7 let's say he retreats
and can you play e5 yet i think you can
just play e5
already if you so choose this is a
perfectly fine way of playing
i think yan playing knight h5 did turn
out to be a mistake
it probably would have been fine if he
went for these more interesting lines of
capturing on h4 or playing that f4
but i just don't think it makes sense to
put these pawns on h6 and g5
and then not go after this bishop okay
let's move on
to the next game once again we're going
to take a look at
another game from this finals match
between
magnus carlson and nyan napomnishi in
this game
yan has the white pieces and we're going
to be looking at
an entirely different type of position
uh when jan had white
in this match he went for some really
crazy positions in the nightdorf
so let's take a look and see what we
have going on here
jan starts the game with the move e4 as
i said
we do end up in the najdorf which magnus
has been playing
a little bit of uh he hasn't always been
the biggest night or player but he's has
been
taking up the challenge lately and in
this game jan went for the move
6 h3 and this is a rather fashionable
way of playing these days
the idea of course is to go for an early
g4
and try to checkmate white
in the game magnus goes for the move e5
knight b3 was white's choice notably
in in general here knight d e2 is a much
more common
idea for white why is knight
de2 much more common well because after
the move g4
white's going to place this knight on g3
and
knights work very very well behind pawns
like this they start fighting
for the same squares but knight p3
certainly
isn't a bad move
uh what's the advantage of knight out
knight b3
well for one you're opening up this
bishop right and against
knight d to e2 these days black is
almost exclusively
playing the move h5 which does make g4 a
little
bit harder to achieve which makes this
not a need to look a little bit
sillier whereas after knight p3 if black
plays the move
h5 now all of a sudden
with this bishop being opened up there
are some very strong
ideas of going for control of the d5
square
for example bishop g5 something like
bishop e7 might be played
and you could even consider capturing
this guy
and going something like bishop c4 just
fighting for the immediate control
of of the d5 square these ideas are sort
of available to white now whereas they
really wouldn't be
with this knight on e2 in the game
magnus chose not to allow this sort of
thing
instead playing the move bishop e7 the
upside to bishop e7
is it's developing the pieces more
quickly playing against these ideas of
bishop g5 or other ideas
of early bishop development by white
the downside of course as you may have
guessed is that it's not the move h5
which means the move g4 is going to come
on the board
as it did in this game
uh now it really would be a bit too much
for black to allow this pawn to g5
when white would very very quickly
start taking over the king's side and
without this knight on f6
black is missing a key defender of the
d5 square
as well as some other important squares
on the queen on the king's side
so in the game magnus plays the move h6
contesting the g5 square
bishop e3 is natural development by
whites
knight bd7 now very natural by black as
well
and now the move a4 is usually a good
idea
for white in these positions just to
slow down any potential plans of b5 and
b4
to gain this space on the queen side and
kick this knight out of the c3 square
where it threatens to come to d5 and
controls the e4 pawn
now magnus plays a pretty interesting
move here
it might not be one that would be
natural do
at first glance but the idea behind it
makes
a lot of sense so that idea is to play
the move
knight to f8 uh so what is knight f8
well not f8 is an attempt
to reroute this knight not actually to
e6 in most cases but instead
over to g6 and on g6 this knight
does a lot of really good things for
black's position
position one it controls a very
important f4
square if white was able to play
something like f4 and f5
then things would start to to look
pretty dire for black
on the king's side with so much space
being taken by these pawns a lot of the
time
white can also threaten to take on e5 as
well after this idea of f4
but from g6 black is doing a great job
of controlling this square
also very very relevant is it does
indirectly
sort of try and discourage the move h4
black is going to be able to plant this
knight on h4 in some cases
to prevent the move h4 from from
happening
now bishop c4 is white's idea once again
this is sort of the advantage to putting
this knight on
b3 rather than on e2 this bishop is open
and magnus follows up with the natural
the natural move
knight g6 oops
okay i do want to mention that
a mistake for black would likely be
castling in this position
this is probably being a bit too kind to
white castling into this attack
with sort of no no resistance
in general in the nydorf and many other
openings where white is launching an
early attack on the king side you can
look at some french
lines for example it can be good to
delay
castling the king until you're a little
bit more prepared either to deal with
the attack
or until white's focus has shifted to
attacking the king somewhere else
uh so that's why we see knight f8 knight
g6
jan chooses the move queen e2 now
with the idea of keeping an eye on these
two things and clearing the way for
queen side castles
uh queenie ii does the other great job
of indirectly defending the e4 pawn
if this net ever wants to move and
magnus simply plays the move
bishop d7 once again at this point
probably castles would be a playable
idea for black because he's added
this additional defender to the king's
side but
still bishop d7 delaying castles for as
long as possible
because he still isn't sure if the king
is going to be safer over there or in
the center
now we see the move f3 and so i'd like
you guys
at home to tell me what the move f3
uh signifies why has black
or why has white played the move f3
yf3
so mateo actually has the right idea
here
uh muhammad says to play knight d5
that's actually not
so much going to be the case here uh
let's see uh black's next move was rook
c8 which we'll talk about in a bit
but knight d5 isn't going to be the best
idea here black is actually
very very happy to trade off the f6
knight for
the c3 knight because it opens up this
bishop and allows him to defend these
dark squares on the king's side
so much more easily than he would
otherwise
uh so mateo uh his idea
was f3 is to play h4 and h5 which of
course is correct
can't do it right now because this guy
is hanging but after f3
this does become a threat so how do you
want to respond
to this idea of playing h4
we have sort of done half the battle
here we know what our opponent wants to
do he's telling
us with the move f3 he wants to play the
move h4
and now we get a move to decide what's
the best way
for us to respond to this idea of h4
what's the best way for us to respond
so chess king says the move knight h7
and this is the move that i would be
very very tempted to play
if i had the black pieces in this
position it's the most direct idea
it's directly challenging the h4 pawn
our opponent likely isn't going to want
to play this as a sacrifice
and it's true that this move might be
okay
for uh for black here the problem is
that
white could simply queenside castle
and now our knight isn't really doing
anything proactive
on the h7 square it's it's a good
defender
of the king side but we can actually see
that white has done a great job of
maintaining a little bit of flexibility
in his position it's true that he was
aiming for
this kingside attack with where he opens
everything up
but also he's placed his pieces very
well for an attack in the center of the
board
and this is something that black has to
keep in mind
so for that reason i don't believe
magnus
really wanted to play the move knight h7
instead he came up with a much more
interesting way of dealing with this
idea
of h4 and that uh method was to play
this move
rook c8 now after the idea of
h4 magnus is very ready
to meet it with the idea of knight h7
h5 and knight h4 uh sorry
not knight h4 but bishop h4 check
so the idea now is that after
for example the exchange sacrifice
white has to solve the issue of
this rook bearing down on the c file and
specifically
attacking this bishop on c4
in the game jan actually castles
queenside which i do think is a pretty
significant mistake because now knight
takes f3
is coming on the board and the exchange
sacrifice for white
no longer makes that much sense
just to explain a little bit more deeply
white goes for this exchange sacrifice
because now of course this knight is
sort of
entirely trapped on the h4 square
but magnus seeing this coming from a
distance
had already placed this work on c8 to be
able to challenge
white's white's hold
on this knight by threatening stuff like
knight takes f3 or even knight g2 to
reroute
using the fact that this bishop is loose
on c4
so this is the type of multi-purpose
move that's
is really making magnus uh so good at
chess right it's easy to see that white
is threatening h4
it's very very difficult to come up with
rook c8
in response to h4 right you know h4 is
coming
you know rook c8 is generally you know a
positive move that you would like to
play
but then to find this justification for
it by playing bishop h4 check and
shoving this knight onto the h4 square
that is very very impressive to to my
mind
uh so what should you take away from
this well
we kind of know some useful moves for
black here are
one of them is definitely going to be
playing the move rook c8 it's just an
active square for the rook it pressures
the bishop it pressures the king after
queen side castles
and so you should always still consider
these useful moves
even when you think your opponent is
making a pretty significant threat
so we know that h4 seems like a
significant threat but you definitely
want to at least consider playing the
move rook c8
right rook see it is a move that you
would like to play so it's worth it to
spend some time
and try to figure out is rix8 a move
that i can play
am i going to be happy with what happens
to the position after rook c8
and so magnus had asked himself this
question he didn't give up on this move
too early
and then he ended up coming up with this
really nice idea
of bishop h4 check takes takes and
knight takes f3 and from this point
forward magnus had
a pretty good control over this game
uh just to mention the move a move like
king f1
actually would be playable here for
whites
but now the downside is of course queen
side castles
is no longer legal that's the main
downside and
black is able to play something like
knight f4
takes takes and let's just
play a move for example something like
bishop back to f6
and while white is definitely still
coming up with some threats here
he's not exactly checkmating on the
king's side it's very difficult to
break through with this pawn structure
in black having good
good control and without the dark
squared bishop this dark squid bishop is
going to be pretty powerful now
for black on this wide open diagonal
definitely would have been an
interesting game
but jan chose to go for queen side
castles instead here
uh which does end up with a worse
position
i will say that white likely had to go
for a move
like bishop d5 and the point of bishop
d5
of course is to renew this trap of the
knight on h4 but now the issue for white
is sort of there's no comfortable way to
actually capture this piece
uh for example bishop d5 is attacking
this pawn
on b7 if rook b8s
the the question arises how do you add
enough attackers to this knight
to actually be able to capture it one
day and i have no
idea to be honest with you play might
continue with something like queenside
castles
uh even kingside castles now for white
or for black
queen f2 to threaten this knight but
after something like b5
rook h1 b4 for example
knight takes f3 queen takes f3 uh we end
up with
an interesting type of position where
white has spent so much time
to collect this knight and it's not a
full piece that white is up
it's two pieces for a rook and
in exchange black already even has the
extra pawn
and some nice play on the queen side to
uh to go along with it so
would have just been an interesting game
from this point forward
instead though we do see yon queen side
castle first
allowing knight takes f3 as i've said
uh jan's idea was to capture back on d6
but now the move queen e7 is very
natural trying to evict this rook and
take control of some more squares
uh the rook comes over to b6 but now
bishop takes g4
and the entire king's side is just
collapsing now
for white after the move bishop d5
threatening b7 black simply takes the
opportunity to castle
of course white is now breaking through
in the center
and black has very much taken control of
the king's side winning all of the
king's side pawns
so now black is much happier to castle
the king king's side
then leave it in this opening center
and from here jan could have sort of
stayed in the game with a fight
trying to take all of the queen side
pawns for example rook b8s
queen takes a6 and black
would probably retreat to the center
trying to take more control over some of
the queen side
because this is where white's idea or
whites play white's ideas are going to
take place now
and it would have been an interesting
game uh what black for the moment is
up the exchange for a single pawn but
white has these three connected pawns on
the queen side
and definitely has some play
in the game though after kingside
castles
white went with queen g2 and this is
sort of the wrong idea here
jan is still trying to make this uh king
side attack
work but with these two pawns missing
while it does open some files for white
it also removes some key attackers right
these pawns are going to be tough to
break
without these white pawns on the king's
side to control some squares
uh queen h4 is black's response just
defending the bishop and not allowing
any tactics
now rook g6 was yon's clever idea taking
advantage of this pin
but black doesn't have to try too hard
to refute this
simply knight h to g5 knight f6 would
have been fine
this knight would have been fine any
move that doesn't hang the bishop
or move the bishop of course and now
black is just totally winning
king b1 played in the game of course
queen e1
was a little bit of a threat and just
bishop back to e6 now
we have if bishop takes e6
then f takes e6 likely would have been
the response uh there's also ideas of
queen e1 check
but we'll just start with f takes e6 and
in the game jan decided he would rather
actually have
the bishop than the rook here so rook
takes c6 played in the game
fe6 and now bishop takes b7 but white is
down
two exchanges now and after the move
queen e1
king or sorry bishop c1 not king a2
rook takes c3 magnus gives back an
exchange
in order to get a crushing advantage on
on the queen's side
and once again this game is is sort of
just over bishop takes e4
queen e4 white does get to capture on
h6 rook f7 defends against the mate the
bishop comes back
queen f5 and playing through these last
moves a little bit more quickly
nothing too exciting happens here black
just up the exchange
has a very easy position the a pawn
falls
and at the end of the day
we're arriving at the end of the day
waiting for me to finish my sentence
rooks are worth more than nights at the
end of the day
is how that sentence ends with no more
checks
and the extra material for magnus well i
did not realize
just how many moves this game goes on
but this is all end game technique
which is boring and white ends up
actually checkmated on the king's side
of the board
i know i played through those end moves
very very quickly
but i didn't want to spend too too much
time on them as black was just totally
winning
with the extra rook if you are
interested in
these types of end games i recommend
checking out the end game class i'm not
going over this end game in particular
but i do go over some very interesting
end games like these
the crux of this game really ends up
being this move rook c8 i think i think
this is sort of
the clever idea by magnus that sort of
uh
started leading yon uh into
the what's what's the quote into the
dark forest
where the path out is is only white
enough for one
and it was white enough for magnus not
wide enough for yon
in these ensuing complications very very
clever idea
to use this rook to play against these
pawns on the king's side
okay we have time i think to go over one
more game quickly
i wanted to go over one of yon's wins in
fact dion's only win
in the match it was a fun game also in
the night or
so i'm gonna go through it rather
quickly we probably don't have enough
time to go into all the complications
but it is worth taking a look at so in
this one
like i said jan has the white pieces and
we are back
in the night orf and jan goes for the
move
rook g1 and i don't know if this is the
official name of the variation
but on lead chess where i'm giving this
lecture
uh it is listed as freak
attack this is the night or variation
freak
attack so one to keep in mind for sure
and the reason i think this move isn't
as popular
it's going for this idea of g4 all the
same
but it is a bit more committal than this
move h3 for example if black plays the
move b5
against h3 ideas of knight d5
are sort of available to white ideas of
g4 as well
and if bishop b7 going for these threats
bishop g2
and this is available to white
to control the e4 pawn where if you
compare with rook g1
b5 g4 bishop b7
all of a sudden bishop g2 it's a little
bit less easy
to uh to play when you're interfering
with your own
piece's control of the g pawn and
support of pushing the g
pawn forward this is still playable
for white and has been played before
but jan's idea here was not to go for
this because honestly
this position is very much just a worse
version for white
of the position with the rook on h1 and
the pawn on h3
so jan justifies his opening by playing
the move g5
and this one is sort of a sort of a wild
one
uh this is in fact a pawn sacrifice
by yan and this is the second time he
played this move in the match
the first time he played this move
magnus carlson played the move knight f
to d7
and actually went on to win the game
since that game i think magnus probably
booked up a bit
and followed through with the move
knight takes e4 instead accepting
this sacrifice and from here we see yon
play some very very interesting chess
we have knight take c4 bishop takes e4
and now the move a4 is the novelty
that jan brings to the table this
position had been seen before
actually a number of times but queen g4
had been played every time this this
appeared
now on this time around we get a4 by yan
and black has a couple of options here
perhaps the simplest is to play the move
b4
when after white tries to challenge this
bishop black can play the move d5
and try and take over the center this is
why sacrificing the e-pawn
is so dangerous because if your opponent
gets just a little bit of extra time
then they're going to be able to take
over the center and once they get
control of the center
it's going to be very difficult to
challenge
challenge them anywhere instead though
magnus plays the move e5 which is sort
of an attempt to get a better version
of playing the move b4 for example if
this knight goes away
to some place like b3 now black's
options
include taking on a4 for example
bringing this bishop back to c6
and once again just sort of taking over
the entire center
rook a5 would be you know a legal chess
move bishop b7
castles and black is doing very very
very well here
instead of all this though we now see
the true nature of
eon's idea and that is to take on b5
he says go ahead capture my
knights and this is actually a pretty
good piece sacrifice
by jan here it's
not the type of sacrifice where yon is
immediately regaining
uh his entire piece but it is giving him
some very very active play
for example if e takes d4 queen takes d4
is hitting this bishop you don't want to
do something like bishop back to b7
because now the killer move might not be
what you
would first think of but it's to
activate the rook on g1
with the move rook g3 coming to e3 with
some killer ideas and the main issue
here for black
is that the move bishop e7 while very
desirable
is not so easy to obtain due to this
pressure
on g7 that being said the move d5
would likely be holding a quality for
black with the idea of knight d7
and giving up this piece this pawn after
all to follow
when black's position is very very
compact
and this bishop on e4 does a great job
of sort of stunting the pressure
that this rook on e3 can provide if
something like f3 as well
then you're sort of asking for a little
bit of trouble around your own king
something like bishop takes c2 and this
king
is sort of lacking squares to uh to run
to
lacking some squares
uh in the game though we saw none of
that instead we see
bishop e7 by magnus carlsen perhaps not
ready to accept this piece sacrifice
when things would be uh
rather crazy rather crazy for him so
bishop e7 instead
we see the move rook g4 now by jan once
again
activating this rook along the g file
showing the point to his early opening
play
and after a takes b5 jan now does not
capture on e4 because this guy is
hanging
and he doesn't take on a8s because that
would solve black's problems
so instead we see the move bishop b5
check knight d7
and bishop d2 sort of keeping the
tension
everywhere
and now unfortunately i do think
unfortunately for magnus that is yan
actually does have
a little bit of an edge in this position
turns out here the move king f8 uh sort
of had to be played and you can kind of
understand
why this is uh the point now is that if
white ever gets this pressure
for example rook takes e4 sorry we're
still hanging this piece for example
bishop d2 rook takes queen takes
something like d5 knight e2
the point is white's pressure on g7 is
really going to be alleviated
before it ever exists there's never
going to be any issues of queen takes g7
with the king on f8 of course black
still has problems to solve here
namely he's very underdeveloped in
exchange
for just one pawn but it is more or less
equality
after knight d7 the issue now is that
the e file could open at any moment
this diagonal is already open and that
leaves the king
squarely on the intersection of two very
dangerous lines
bishop d2 played in the game this bishop
comes back to b7
and now knight f5 is sort of the killer
blow here
magnus thought he could castle to avoid
a hassle
but it turns out the hassle was
following him
anyways and so white already
is able to win the game with his next
move so white to move and win and then
i will show you what jan played in the
game which might also win
although it is in a little bit of a less
obvious manner
so wait to move and win
and i'm noticing we're running out of
time so i'm going to reveal the answer
now pause if you don't want it spoiled
for you
white to move and win the move rook g to
a4
is actually the idea and this is a
highly counter-intuitive move
the reason this move is winning is it
because
it turns out black's seventh rank is
simply too weak
in in this case you always see ideas of
the rook coming to the seventh and being
very powerful
and capturing pawns in this case
you're gonna end up with a rook coming
to the seventh and being very powerful
capturing full pieces uh for example if
rook takes a4
rook takes a4 bishop takes g5 isn't
enough
because bishop g5 queen g5 bishop d7
is winning a full piece and so
there's simply no way to deal with all
the threats rookie 8 means rook a7
when you see this rook just coming
through with devastating effect
bishop c8 and bishop a5 now and this guy
is is just too stuck
knight b6 would be playable but this is
hanging this is hanging
this is hanging too much for black so
rook ga4 was missed in the game instead
rook takes a bishop takes a8
and jan is winning anyways but with an
attack on the king's side
rather than this attack along the
seventh rank
so rook h4 g6 is magnus carlsen's idea
but now queen g4 is very clever by yan
uh the point being if you capture this
guy queen h5
is forced checkmate and yan is
threatening to go queen h3 as well we
see
knight c5 and now jan
actually misses the only move to win the
only move to win
in this position is very very incredibly
the move king f1 which probably makes no
sense to you
didn't make any sense to me either but
it's the move that stockfish finds
to win the game uh i'll tell you why in
just a moment
but let's see the game continuation
first queen h3 was played in the game
magnus tries to move h5 to keep keep
things closed
but any attacking player will tell you
the answer here
sacrifice this rook you don't need that
guy takes takes
knight e6 and magnus resigned before yon
could play a move
g6 to follow and this is just
devastating for example here
free stuff f7 free stuff
king h8 checkmate all
going quite well for white so
what was the magical draw for black
after queen h3
why doesn't this move win well turns out
bishop g5
is enough for a perpetual check bishop
d2
king d2 queen g5 king c3
knight e4 king b4 g takes
f5 check check
take the rook queen d2 and
white is getting perpetual checked
believe it or not
and so this is why king f1 was the only
move to win because then bishop takes d2
would not come with check
here if you play king f1 by the way just
the simple
captures and this is not checkmate as
the queen cannot step to h6
okay very fun game between jan and
magnus to end the lecture on hopefully
you guys
enjoyed this uh once again that's the
only game that jan won
in the two mini matches played between
magnus and jan in the finals
magnus with a truly dominating
performance proving that he
is in fact a chess legend uh if you're
watching live be sure to stick around
we're gonna have a couple more classes
tonight
uh up next is the end game class still
right here
on youtube i'm gonna be going over some
end games
to decide the next world championship
challenger
that is of course end games from this
year's
uh candidates tournament or at least the
first half of it
uh with all that in mind thank you so
much for joining me this week on the
road to 2000
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
you